sheldon adelson the billionaire behind
one of the world's largest casino and
resort empires
died monday night at the age of 87. the
long-time ceo and chairman of las vegas
sands
adelson got his start in the casino
business at age 55
when he and his partners bought the
sands hotel and casino in las vegas for
128 million dollars
he owned more than half of the
multi-billion dollar gambling empire
which spanned las vegas
singapore and macau china born to
immigrant parents in boston
adelson showed his business potential at
an early age selling newspapers at 12
and owning multiple vending machines by
16. edelson
soon got into finance helping small
businesses go public and brokering
commercial mortgages in boston
in the late 2000s after a rapid
expansion the market's downturn
threatened the sands empire he had built
and cut his personal net worth from 28
billion dollars to 3 billion
but adelson doubled down on his holdings
in asia and backed his company with
millions of his own fortune
moves that ultimately saved sans and
rejuvenated adelson's wealth
with the wealth from his company adelson
was a prolific donor to right-wing
causes in both the us
and israel adelson was also a crucial
backer of president donald trump
contributing to his 2016 campaign and
then generously backing his re-election
bid
forbes calculated that adelson and his
wife miriam poured more than 215 million
dollars into causes supporting trump and
the gop
in the 2020 election cycle adelson was
worth 35.1 billion dollars as of march
according to forbes
you